there's a lot to chew on in that
long-awaited new spider-man teaser to
the point that it's hard to catch
everything even a multiple viewings from
comic book parallels to some blink in
your missing moments here are all the
small details you missed in the
spider-man no way home trailer
one of the most interesting sequences in
the trailer sees tom holland's peter
parker riding a train through some kind
of desert landscape as dr strange uses
magic to duplicate and rotate the cars
while it's not entirely clear what's
going on between the characters there
one element has caught the attention of
some marvel fans online specifically the
train looks a whole lot like the
elevated train that toby maguire's
spider-man and alfred molina's doctor
octopus have an epic fight on in 2004's
spider-man 2. given the confirmed
presence of molina in no way home as
well as the rumored inclusion of
maguire's version of peter parker
there's plenty of reason to believe the
train is the same one from spider-man 2.
if it is actually the spider-man 2 train
then it's likely that it like dark ark
may be spilling over into the mcu
reality as a result of his and
stranger's botched attempt to rewrite
reality but whether it's actually
important to the film's plots or just a
fun easter egg for fans that may very
well be the train maguire's peter
stopped while amassed from crashing
disastrously and spider-man 2.
we won't tell nobody
building off the events of 2019
spider-man far from home which ended
with peter parker's secret identity
being revealed to the world by j jonah
jameson spider-man no way home focuses
heavily on peter parker trying to return
his life to normal the main way peter
tries to do that is by asking doctor
strange to cast a spell that reverses
what happened at the end of far from
home predictably things don't go
according to plan the film's plot feels
very reminiscent of what happens in a
pair of infamous spider-man comic book
story lines in 2007's one more day peter
parker and mary jane watson parker make
a deal with the demonic mephisto to
erase their marriage from existence in
exchange for saving aunt may's life in
the 2010 sequel story one moment in time
peter asked dr strange to erase the
public's knowledge of a secret identity
given the fallout of his and mary jane's
agreement with the demon and after some
convincing the sorcerer supreme agrees
for what it's worth it doesn't seem like
the no way home filmmakers are unaware
of these parallels there's even a
protest sign in the trailer of tom
holland's peter parker with devil horns
and the words devil in disguise scrawled
underneath his photo which feels like a
reference to the role that mephisto
plays in the one more day comic
early on in the spider-man no way home
trailer peter parker is interrogated by
the authorities over his alleged
involvement in the death of mysterio at
first glance the scene doesn't seem
particularly noteworthy though there's
been some speculation about a particular
lawyer what we know for sure though is
that those aren't just any government
officials as a matter of fact they're
damage control agents as revealed by a
jacket worn by one of the agents the
organization originally founded by
shield and later turned into a joint
venture between stark industries and the
us government specializes in cleaning up
the destruction caused by superhero
battles and in the maintenance of all
weapons and artifacts left over from the
scenes of said battles damage control is
notably the same organization that sends
adrian tombs down his path of villainy
in 2017's spider-man homecoming
he's right i overextended myself
while the organization's involvement in
spider-man no way home doesn't reveal
anything new about the movie's plot that
we didn't already know it's a fun easter
egg for marvel cinematic universe fans
and acts as just yet another link
between no way home and the previous tom
holland-led spider-man films
about halfway through the teaser there's
a very brief shot of tom holland's peter
parker running through a cafeteria while
wearing a black and gold spider-man suit
it has been known for quite some time
now that no way home would feature a
black and gold variation of the
traditional spider-man suit however with
the film rumored to feature not just tom
holland's peter parker but also toby
mcguire and andrew garfield's iterations
of the character it wasn't always clear
which spider-man would actually wear it
and no way home prior to the trailer's
release some fans even thought that it'd
be garfield's peter parker who donned
the new threads in the film with the
spider-man no way home trailer
officially released we know now that
that's not the case while there's still
the chance that garfield and maguire's
peter parkers will wear their own unique
super suits in the film assuming they're
actually in it the spider-man no way
home trailer seems to confirm that it'll
be holland's pizza who wears a
previously revealed black and gold suit
the same sequence in the spider-man no
way home trailer that sees peter parker
wearing his fancy new black and gold
suit also features a blink in your
missid comic book easter egg a poster on
the wall behind peter features the
acronym feast which has led some marvel
fans to speculate that the cafeteria
peter is running through in the trailer
is part of a feast shelter that's fairly
big news because it opens up the
possibility for a spider-man villain
named martin lee also known as mr
negative to appear in the comics feast
is a charity founded by lee as a front
for his criminal activities as mr
negative
though mae parker eventually takes over
the charity on her own lee is still
intrinsically linked to the organization
for many comic book fans or fans of the
ps4 spider-man video game where it was a
major presence that makes a hint of
feast in spider-man no way home
particularly exciting especially given
all the ongoing rumors and speculation
surrounding the film's film lineup could
mr negative be one of the film's
surprise antagonists it's impossible to
say right now but the appearance of a
feast poster and the spider-man no way
home trailer certainly makes that seem
like a very real possibility we'll know
for sure when spider-man no way home
finally swings into theaters on december
17th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you